[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de la grande interview il y a
tout juste un siècle la france crée ses
premières unités pour gérer les
manifestations
c'est la naissance de la gendarmerie
mobile et ses missions notamment et bien
canaliser les foules retarde l usage de
la violence et des unités qui seront
renforcés par la police nationale en
1944 avec la création des crs alors
depuis 100 ans le maintien de l'ordre
évolue sans cesse en fonction des
différentes crises sociales les émeutes
de la nuit du 6 février 1934 les
manifestations de mai 1968 ou plus
récemment la crise des gilets jaunes
sont autant d'événements qui font date
et qui suscite aussi le débat alors pour
en parler nous accueillons le général de
gendarmerie françois de la soujeole mon
général bonjour bonjour olivier merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
vous êtes aujourd'hui en deuxième
section c'est à dire que vous n'êtes
plus en activité vous avez occupé tous
les postes de commandement dévolu à un
officier de gendarmerie mais pas
seulement puisque vous êtes l'un des
pionniers de la recherche historique sur
le maintien de l'ordre expliquez nous
dans quel but avez vous fait ses
recherches
mais il se trouve que quand j'étais
jeune capitaine au sortir du
commandement un escadron de gendarmerie
mobile j'ai eues j'étais affecté à la
direction générale de la gendarmerie un
toast de permanence
en contact avec les autorités
gouvernementales notamment pour
permettre à la direction la gendarmerie
d'être très réactif sur les
sollicitations et ce type de poste me
laisser une relative disponibilité j'ai
décidé de meubler en reprenant des
études universitaires
parce que notamment j'avais remarqué
qu'il y avait pas de travaux dignes de
ce nom pour la gendarmerie qui peut pour
son histoire alors le maintien de
l'ordre une doctrine qui est à la fois
saluée dans le monde on entend souvent
parler d'excellence française en termes
de maintien de l'ordre elle est aussi
critiquée ces dernières années notamment
avec la crise des gilet jaune a marqué
par de forts affrontements entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
quelle leçon
aujourd'hui on peut déjà tirer de ces
événements vous qui avez un regard
historique justement dans la première
observation que je voudrais faire c'est
que quand on observe le maintien de
l'ordre en france au cours du 20e siècle
et début du 21e il ya extrêmement peu de
victimes même si un mort au maintien de
l'ordre et qu'une catastrophe est tout à
fait déplorable mais si on se remet en
perspective
des statistiques à cet égard et eu très
peu de tuer au maintien de l'ordre en
france ce qui effectivement met en
exergue la maîtrise de la violence
kessel les professionnels de cette
fonction en france pour autant on est
évidemment perfectible ya toujours une
recherche de progrès d'adéquation la
riposte par rapport à la menace c'est
pour ça qu'en 1969 on a créé donc à
l'issue de mai 68 une véritable école de
maintien de l'ordre a certes acier dans
le massif central pour suivre au plus
près
les évolutions de ce maintien de leurs
les évolutions des modes opératoires des
manifestants pour avoir vraiment une
riposte en adéquation avec le niveau de
menace alors la formation va justement
d'y revenir dans quelques instants mais
pour revenir sur ces manifestations on a
vu des personnes gravement blessées on a
entendu aussi le terme violences
policières aujourd'hui les méthodes de
des forces de l'ordre sont jugées
parfois trop violente par certains
tandis que il ya aussi ce malaise qui
s'accroît chez les forces de l'ordre qui
se sentent jugé qu' ce sont des cibles
ce débat sur les violences policières
est ce qu'il a toujours existé au fil de
l'histoire ou alors il est
particulièrement prégnant ces dernières
années il a toujours existé et et quand
on observe notamment
l'analyse qui a été fait du 6 février 34
parce que c'est la première grande
manifestation parisienne avec une
violence redoutable à laquelle étaient
confrontés la garde républicaine mobile
de l'époque
et les critiques formulées à ce moment
là ont été redoutables on a même pu
craindre à cette époque là la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile tant la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui semblait
être le s qui était réellement le noyau
dur du dispositif de maintien d'ordre à
l'époque il y avait eu effectivement une
quinzaine de morts en février 34 à
partir delà de cette date phare quelles
sont les leçons qui s'en tirer et
finalement pour la suite
alors les leçons qui sont tirés la
première leçon tirée par un rapport
parlementaire de l'époque c'est de faire
en sorte que la garde républicaine
mobile la gendarmerie mobile somme soit
vraiment dans la main de ses chefs parce
que l'une des erreurs commises en 1934
pour défendre
le pont débouchant sur l'assemblée
nationale et face à la place de la
concorde c'est le fait que la garde
répétées la garde républicaine mobile
était mélangé des gardiens de la paix et
donc mode opératoire différent
réaction différente et il en est résulté
une certaine confusion un manque de
cohésion et coordination et ça ça a été
un des grands enseignements ne plus
mélanger
les forces de différents statuts au
maintien d'europe parce que il ya bien
sûr des formations qui se ressemblent
mais il y à une troupe qui doit rester
dans la main de son chef vous le disiez
tout à l'heure la formation est arrivée
plus tard après mai 68 mais aujourd'hui
comment on forme ses hommes parce que
finalement on les voit dans les
manifestations il encaisse il encaisse
il encaisse et parfois là encore on a pu
le voir quand il s'agit de lâcher les
troupes eh bien on a vu des images d'un
des débordements de certains notamment
des crs on souvient sur les champs
elysées au moment là encore des crises
de gilet jaune alors comment on les
forme ses hommes
de nous relier moi je voulais dire une
chose
la pause est tout de suite en guise de
préalable vous évoquez les crs moi ce
que je peux témoigner d'abord je suis
aussi de gendarmerie dont vous
appartient pas de trop développé le
sujet de la formation des crs mais je
sais qu'ils sont très bien formés ils
ont une école de maintien de l'ordre à
nîmes garons où il étudie de leur côté
donc toutes les évolutions du maintien
de l'ordre donc que ce soit en
gendarmerie mobile ou du côté des crs il
ya un grand souci de maîtrise de la
deûle usage de la force et il semble que
un des enseignements tirés des
mouvements dg john je parle avec les
circonstances et la circonspection
d'historiens savez qu'historien de tous
il veut prendre du recul par rapport à
l'actualité il faut du recul pour
analyser avec justesse mais ce qu'on
peut peut être dire c'est que il ya eu
beaucoup plus j'allais dire de problèmes
dans les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre avec des forces qui n'étaient
pas des professionnels
que sont les crs et les gendarmes
mobiles
parce que c'est vrai que ces forces
traditionnelles
professionnaliser ont été mises à rude
épreuve sur une longue période et il a
fallu les renforcer
ce sont les forces de vents forts qui
n'avaient pas le même degré de maîtrise
voilà justement et éclairé noom
justement éclairez nous parce qu'on a vu
lors de ces manifestations notamment
alors effectivement les gendarmes
mobiles les crs formés pour le maintien
de l'ordre et puis avec d'autres unités
de police on a vidé des brigades
anticriminalité également engagé sur le
terrain comment est-ce que ça s'organise
un maintien de l'ordre finalement quand
la situation est délicate
non olive et vous comprendrez que
moi-même compétences et l'essentiel mans
gendarmique bien sûr je suis un
observateur que vous à l'observateur
averti mais je ne me retiens pas de trop
développer cet aspect de renforts aux
forces traditionnelles que sont les crs
et la gendarmerie mobile je suis en tant
qu'historien parce que voilà bien sûr je
suis officier de gendarmerie mais mais
c'est le regard de l'historien que je
souhaite poser
je dis simplement que les forces de
renforts ne vais pas le même degré de
maîtrise voilà que les crs ou les
gendarmes mobiles et qu'à partir de là
effectivement il ya davantage de risques
que l'adéquation de la riposte soit pas
parfaitement injuste et la menace alors
en tout cas il a fallu intervenir parce
qu'il ya aussi on voit dans ces
rassemblements ces manifestations des
groupuscules particulièrement violent on
pense notamment aux blacks blocs qui
sont souvent montrés comme étant violent
à l'endroit des forces de l'ordre est ce
que c'est un phénomène relativement
nouveau
ces groupuscules qui s'en prennent
directement forces de l'ordre oui oui
c'est un phénomène relativement nouveau
qui pose un vrai problème parce que
quelles que soient les intentions des
organisateurs des manifestations qui
j'allais dire jouent le jeu démocratique
il ya une manifestation de
mécontentement qui veut s'exprimer
certes mais il ya un dialogue avec la
préfecture de police de paris notamment
et le phénomène nouveau c'est que les
black box
cette mouvance anarchiste n'a aucunement
l'intention de respecter ce jeu là et
donc c'est une une composante qui
cherchent donc à détruire
et à exprimer une violence caractérisée
et ça c'est un problème dès lors que ce
type d'initiative s'immisce au sein
d'une manifestation et de façon
systémique donc là il ya un vrai
problème pour les les forces de l'ordre
qui pour appréhender ce phénomène
doivent être en nombre avec notamment
des unités spécialisées dans
l'intervention
c'est vrai que ce qui est délicat
finalement hormis ces groupuscules
identifié c'est finalement les forces de
l'ordre lors d'une manifestation
quand on est un gendarme quand on a un
policier un crs on peut finalement se
retrouver peut-être devant son frère un
cousin
devant des amis par exemple qui
manifeste est ce que on est formés à ça
on est préparé finalement à la foule tir
en face de nous quand on est gendarmes
ou crs oui oui on est parfaitement le
genre mobile parfaitement préparé à
faire face à ce débordement de violence
et a encaissé
sans avoir à riposter
j'allais dire d'emblée
donc ça c'est vraiment une formation à
saint-astier qui est extrêmement bien
mené avec des décomptes exercice de jour
de nuit avec des barricades en flammes à
réduire avec l'emploi de moyens
spécialisés fourgon
exercice avec le port du masque ça il
faut reconnaître que le centre national
de formation la gendarmerie à
saint-astier est extrêmement bien
j'allais dire structurer et à des
instructeurs remarquable il est aussi
commandé par des chaînes de toute
première envergure
ce qui permet à nos escadron de
s'entraîner
jaillir dans des conditions très
réaliste entraînements difficiles dit on
me refasse il s'agit sûrement pas de
guerre on observera notre vocabulaire ne
part pas d'ennemis mais l'adversaire
avec comme règle de toujours d'ailleurs
laissé porte de sortie
il nous reste quelques secondes avant la
pause d'un an - vous évoquez les
barricades en feu on pense à mai 68 1
quand on parle de barricades là encore
quels enseignements de ces
manifestations de mai 68 par rapport au
maintien de l'ordre est bien le goal de
gros enseignements ça a été l'équipement
de nouveaux gendarmes mobiles parce qu'à
l'époque il y avait pas grand chose
quand on regarde toute l'iconographie de
l'époque on se rend compte qu'ils
n'avaient pas de protection du visage
et puis en cours d'événements on a vu
apparaître des grilles de protection
plus ou moins bien adaptés aux casques
et
les gendarmes partent eux maintien de
leur vareuse ou éventuellement avec le
manteau trois-quarts pas du tout à
l'égout driller a reçu et baudriers on
pouvait les gens là on pouvait se
rattraper par le baudrier donc il ya
vraiment eu à l'issue de mai 68 une
étude spécifique sur les équipements et
également sur les véhicules de classe où
les protéger alors ce que je vous
propose c'est de revenir justement sur
l'évolution de ce matériel au maintien
de l'ordre mais avant on va faire une
toute petite pause à tout de suite sur
la pour la grande interview sur rtl
france
[Musique]
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez pour la
deuxième partie de cette grande
interview et non par l'histoire du
maintien de l'ordre avec le général de
gendarmerie
françois de la soujeole alors nous
parlions à l'instant de l'équipement
dans le maintien de l'ordre puisque
c'est vrai que l'histoire du maintien de
l'ordre c'est aussi l'évolution de
l'équipement des véhicules blindés
d'ailleurs vont équiper prochainement
les unités de gendarmerie
il y a aussi du matériel qui est parfois
décrié on pense aux ailes bd ou encore
les grenadains certaines d'ailleurs
interdite depuis la mort de rémy fraysse
l'histoire at elle montré parfois un
usage disproportionné de la force lors
je crois que l'on peut surtout
considérer qu'il ya une vraie maîtrise
de de l'emploi des des armes dévolu à la
gendarmerie ya eu en fait des
circonstances exceptionnelles qui ont pu
déboucher sur
en fait des drames mais
c'est pas vraiment un usage
disproportionné
c'est simplement que la panoplie des
outils mis à la disposition dans des
consciences des circonstances très
particulières ont pu donner des effets
tout à fait regrettable
est ce qu'on peut observer aussi c'est
que dans la foulée de ces événements
dramatiques
il ya une révision de ses armements pour
que l'on soit dans l'adéquation
la plus la puce souhaitable bon la
grenade offensive
qui malencontreusement est
dramatiquement a coûté la vie à rémy
fraysse a été retiré
il ya une analyse par l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie des effets de
la loi dalo france ils ont fait un effet
de souffle et un effet sonore mais
c'était pas du tout une arme destinée à
tuer pas du tout pour l'improbable s'est
produit des enseignements rapides ont
été tirés et une nouvelle munition a été
mise au point pour conserver en fait un
effet de souffle mais pour ne plus avoir
l'effet brisant que pouvait avoir une
grenade offensive face à un obstacle
donc et même chose pour eux je a saturé
d'informations nos téléspectateurs mais
en fait il y avait une grenade également
mixte lacrymogènes en grande densité
plus l'effet de souffle celle ci aussi a
été retiré parce que
hisser les produits que des manifestants
un peu trop peau dassieu vouloir
relancer ce type de munition sur les
forces de l'ordre eh bien on eu la
marche et il ya aussi effectivement le
lbb ya eu ces m'a arraché qu'on a vu
avec ses jeunes années il ya eu aussi le
lbd comment est ce que c'est c'est
encadré tout cela l'emploi juridiquement
alors c'est intéressant de vous parler
du npd parce que on dit souvent c'est
une arme de guerre
pour dire c'est totalement inadapté
maintient dos en réalité
quelques employés au maintien de l'ordre
ce n'est pas une arme de guerre pour
qu'on en parle et par sa munition
une ogive en caoutchouc ça peut être
employé les d'autres munitions dans un
contexte de guerre mais c'est pas le cas
là les munitions employées font que
c'est une arme de maintien de l'ordre
donc voyez les une ambiguïté là dessus
et suivant qu'on veut être hostiles ou
non on peut insister sur le fait que le
npd avec d'autres munitions qui sont
jamais employé machado peut-être
considéré comme une arme de guerre donc
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que dans un
escadron de gendarmerie mobile on en
trouve une part peloton
servi par un sous-officier
spécialisé qualifié pour l'emploi de
cette arme et qu' elle est employée dans
des conditions bien particulières jamais
à moins de 10 mètres et pas au delà 30
mètres parce que la transmettra une
flèche de la munition qui fait que l'on
perd en précision et c'est le thorax qui
doit être visée exclusivement et
j'ajouterais que dans le concept
d'emploi gendarmerie mobile elle est le
plus souvent employés avec la cellule
images
maintien de l'ordre de l'escadron
qui est là pour filmer d'abord pour
prouver le contexte d'emploi est un
contexte d'emploi proche de la légitime
défense
et pour montrer que les règles ont été
bien respectées et quand je vous raconte
tout ça olivier c'est simplement pour
revenir sur le fait qu'une délégation
parlementaire à l'issue des
manifestations des dijonnais demandé à
se rendre à l'école de formation du
maintien de l'ordre de la gendarmerie à
saint-astier avec m'a-t-on dit à
l'époque l'idée de faire interdire
la pêche aux achats bélisle est visée
parce que des visages avait été visé
justement vous nous disiez que il
fallait que les soirs choristes
de la formation en fait employé par des
forces qui avait pas été aussi
d'informer à l'emploi duel bd ni
contrôlées par leur hiérarchie donc les
statistiques là dessus donc en fait
l'école de saint-astier a montré le
souci d'encadrement strict de l'emploi
duel bd ce qui fait que la délégation
parlementaire est reparti avec l'idée
que c'est un outil qui pouvait être
conservée donc tout dépend de l'emploi
tout dépend du contrôle et la cour
spécialisée les vrais professionnels du
maintien de l'ordre n'emploient pas le
lbd à tort et à travers et en
gendarmerie ce que je peux vous dire
c'est dans la plupart des cas il ya les
cellules image qui est là pour filmer
parce qu'elle est important aussi de
fournir aux journalistes qui sont en
recherche d'informations les
circonstances d'emploi on sait que font
donc on va nous demander les comptes
dont on a sept
cette rigueur est également cette
prudence dans l'emploi d'une arme
efficace mais qui doivent être employés
dans des conditions très précises avec
olivier si vous permettez je le
comprends votre souci de d'éclairage de
l'actualité mais vous l'avez dit en
préambule c'est centenaire de la
création de la gendarmerie mobile et
j'aurais voulu dire à nos
téléspectateurs les éclairer sur le
contexte de création de cette force
parce que d'abord ma compétence première
ici est celle du regard de l'historien
et je crois que ça peut intéresser nos
téléspectateurs de savoir justement de 8
ans
telle est la prise de conscience des
autorités civiles justement à ce moment
là pour se dire voilà ça ne va pas il
faut qu'on crée unités spécialisées pour
gérer les mouvements de foule qu'est-ce
qui se passe bon il ya eu un long
cheminement avec une dramatisation vers
la fin du 19e siècle tout le monde
connaît le la date du 1er mai 1891 avec
à fourmies donc un bataillon
d'infanterie qui répliquent par des tirs
à des simples jets de pierre avec
notamment femmes et enfants qui meurent
en face alors ça déjà ça a été une prise
de conscience manifeste mais pour autant
les projets parlementaires et qui ont
été soumis à l'époque mais a été adopté
par ce que il y avait donc la chambre
des députés des réticences de
parlementaires qui avaient connu jeune
la commune
et qui avait en tête notamment les
régiments gendarmerie qui était donc le
fer de lance de cette armée versaillaise
mis sur pied par adolphe thiers et qui
disait si on constitue une force de
professionnels on va avoir une garde
prétorienne et dangereuse pour le
pouvoir et ça n'en veut pas et il a
fallu une succession d'événements
qui ont rappelé l'inadéquation de la
troupe d'ailleurs les
la troupe s'était pas du tout on se
sentait pas à l'aise dans ce genre de
mission c'était pas sa fonction première
donc toute une série de maintien de
l'ordre avec des blessés et des tués on
rappellera au passage la grande crise
viticole de 1907 qui a été vraiment
dramatique non pas tant par le nombre de
morts un lieu quelques morts à narbonne
quand même mais le 17ème régiment
d'infanterie d'agde a carrément micro
sans l'air a refusé de marcher en
matière d'or pourquoi parce que c'était
des fils de viticulteurs qui faisait
leur service national
du coup comment sais tu comment le
gouvernement s'adapter justement à ce
type de situation
georges clemenceau à l'époque en 1907
l'a pas entendu de cette oreille pour
lui il fallait continuer avec
circonspection à employer la troupe donc
il y en eu voyez le bataillon du xviie
d'infanterie en tunisie
avec son commandant en tête en guise de
punition
il n'y a pas eu de véritables
enseignements encore tiré en 1907 il
faut attendre en fait la première guerre
mondiale et puis l'union sacrée de
toutes les composantes de la nation
française dans les tranchées pour que au
lendemain de cette première guerre
mondiale avec les mouvements sociaux qui
redémarre et la création du parti
socialiste à tour les grandes
manifestations
de la cgt pour se dire c'est plus
possible d'employer la troupe parce que
on aurait à sa phase des gens qui ont
combattu ensemble dans les mêmes tranché
en est ça ça n'est plus possible donc on
a ressorti des cartons léogé
parlementaire d'avant guerre avec une
force carrément probante
une écoute de sept chambres
parlementaires bleu horizon qui voulait
plus employer la troupe au maintien et
là on a pu aussi avec l'habilité du
directeur de la gendarmerie de l'époque
le colonel plique qui a été un homme
extraordinaire qui a fait un lobby un
lobbying extraordinaire vis-à-vis
parlementaire et qui les a rassurés en
leur disant écoutez on va créer pour
éviter une grave une garde prétorienne
et peloton mobile de 40 heures il y en
aura un autre chef lieu
de chaque préfecture un de chaque
département et en plus on y mettra des
jeunes gendarmes qui seront formés
il me reste deux ans donc là il n'y a
aucun risque de constitution d'une garde
prétorienne
bien sur l'ossature sera constitué de
gradés et d'officiers expérimentés
pour dix font diffuser leurs savoirs
savoir être savoir faire face à une
foule et olemps cela qu'on crée la garde
républicaine mobile donc en 1921 et tout
au long de cette histoire parce qu'on
parlait de l'évolution du matériel et
peut-être aussi de l'évolution des
manoeuvres commencent à évoluer parce
que même ces dernières années on a vu
des techniques un peu des tactiques en
tout cas un peu différente sur le
terrain alors comment ces événements mai
68 février 34 ont senti l'impact et si
on l'évolution des manoeuvres alors donc
il ya une montée en compétence
évidemment qui s'observe au cours des
années 20 des années 30 et le 6 février
34 20 juin un rôle majeur dont j'allais
dire l'acceptation de la gendarmerie
mobile de la garde républicaine mobile
comme force professionnel je vous disais
tout à l'heure ça n'est pas allé de soi
parce que il ya eu ces quinze morts le 6
février 1934 et
la force qui a été l'objet de toutes les
critiques journalistiques ça a été la
garde républicaine bobby parce que je
vous le disais c'est elle qui avait qui
crevait l'écran si je puis dire avec le
savez le casque adrian le casque du
poilu mais version peint en noir rap et
de la grenade or
c'est impressionné ça se voyait
davantage que la tenue des gardiens de
la paix et ça passait à tort en fait
pour la force vraiment agressive à qui
on pouvait imputer ces quinze morts pour
la commission parlementaire a montré que
en réalité ce n'était pas uniquement à
la garde républicaine mobile qu'on
pouvait attribuer
ces 15 mois en fait c'était très
partagés comme responsabilité est en
tout cas le fait de ne pas avoir employé
cette force sous les ordres de ses chefs
et de l'avoir mélange était une erreur
majeure et ce n'est pas
mon vieux registre petit mot allez-y il
nous restera à quelques secondes je
voudrais vous entendent aussi sur
l'évolution parce que on se rend compte
qu'il ya des femmes maintenant
aujourd'hui dans les rangs on y va mais
il voulait se terminer à leonardo et je
dire simplement que en février 34 on
peut vraiment craindre la disparition
d'un mobile tant la presse se déchaîne
injustement et puis on voit une un
soutien politique notamment le président
albert lebrun qui remet au colonel
nicolet le commandant de la 1ère région
garde républicaine mobile qui avait été
tout à fait en avant si ferrer en katy
du rhum est
l'étendard des formations monde est
monté la garde républicaine mobile donc
témoignage de confiance du président de
la république et puis surtout dès 1935
avec toutes les manifestations de
province on voit la presse qui commence
a
salué l'action de la mobile dans dix ans
ils sont bien formés y résistent ils
ceux qui se prennent des coups sans
répliquer immédiatement ils ont le calme
des vieilles troupes on a été injuste
avec eux le 6 février 34 et à partir de
36 il y aura d'ailleurs 37 une
manifestation très sévère place clichy à
paris où le président de la diète ira y
aura des morts en 37 aussi et le
président daladier un prétendu conseil
era la gendarmerie mobile n'a usé que
c'est cross
aux journalistes il le dira après une
enquête sérieuse bon voilà l'image de
marque et les gagner
on peut dire en 1937 et je terminerai en
disant que la garde républicaine mobile
qui ne comptait que quatre mille hommes
à sa création en 1921 en compte 21
milles en juin 40 21 mille gendarmes
mobiles dont les officiels et
sous-officiers constituer les noyaux de
constitution de régiment d'infanterie
dans la réserve ceci pour rappeler notre
statut militaire et l'importance qui
étaient dévolues à la garde républicaine
mobile un adjudant chef de garde
républicaine mobile était chef de
section dans un régiment d'infanterie de
réserve à la déclaration de guerre aux
jeunes car il nous reste quelques
secondes mon général peut-être pour
conclure cette évolution puisque à cette
époque là les rangs de son composée que
d'hommes et puis aujourd'hui je le
disais tout à l'heure on voit des femmes
maintenant qu'ils sont dans les rangs de
des unités de gendarmerie mobile lors de
maintien de l'ordre comment est-ce que
ça arrive et après quel constat
finalement
c'est arrivé donc pas re volonté
politique d'ouvrir tous les métiers aux
femmes je me souviens d'une réunion à
laquelle j'avais participé au ministère
de la défense je représentais en tant
que chef du bureau de la formation de la
dggn la gendarmerie nationale est en
fait la marine et nous-mêmes avions été
un petit peu pointé du doigt on nous
dise écouter les deux seuls endroits
dans les forces armées il n'y a pas de
femmes ce sont les souvenirs et les gens
et mobile alors messieurs il va falloir
réviser pour voir d'autres copies et la
copie a été revue
et nous avons aujourd'hui des escadrons
de gendarmerie mobile qui sont commandés
par des femmes des pelotons qui sont
commandés par les femmes est également
des gendarmes mobiles durand qui sont
des femmes et ça se passe très bien
et c'est une nouvelle culture donc qu'il
nous a fallu qui nous a fallu acquérir
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un
temps de réflexion à propos de la
violence surtout au cours des
manifestations nous avions peur que la
violence se focalise sur l'élément
féminin dans un élément de contact et
les modes opératoires ou intégrer
parfaitement l'élément féminin on a vu
qu'avec eux qualifiés féminin beaucoup
de de savoir être et de savoir faire de
commandement donc voilà on s'adresse une
force quand même qui est essentiellement
masculine mais au sein de laquelle les
phares vous montrer
leur capacité manoeuvrière et leurs
capacités de conception de manoeuvre
celle chantée officiers nous arrivons au
terme de cette émission un grand merci
en tout cas à vous général françois de
la soujeole d'avoir partagé sur le
plateau de la grande interview vos
travail sur l'histoire du maintien de
l'ordre en france mais aussi votre
réaction par rapport aux dernières
actualités cette émission est à revoir
sur notre site rt france pointé vais
vous pouvez également l'écouter en
podcast à très bientôt sur notre antenne
vous
[Musique]